hey David why is Andrew yang surging in
the polls this is a good question first
we have to address the facts is Andrew
yang surging in the polls as of this
recording
Andrew yang has recently pulled three
and four in a couple of polls like for
example there's an emerson poll where
andrew yang has pulled four there's a
Quinnipiac poll where Andrew yang has
pulled three there's a slightly older
USA Today poll where Andrew yang has
pulled three and he's averaging about
2.5% so at one point he was only polling
1% in that sense Andrew yang clearly has
some momentum I think the better
argument we're talking about Yang's
appeal is the accelerated donor base
that Andrew yang has picked up while
many other one in Super Centers have not
even gotten enough donations to qualify
for the third debate that's coming up
next week and yes I think increased
social media attention also can tell us
about interest in Andrew yang if not
electoral support do I think Andrew yang
is rocketing up in the polls no I mean
he's still averaging two point five
percent and he's made the third debate
stage that's great I've interviewed him
I like him I'm glad to see him there I
want to hear his ideas but there is not
evidence at this point that there is
going to be much more Headroom so to
speak for Andrew yang to take advantage
of although I'm sure people hearing me
talk about this will disagree the reason
I believe Andrew yang is getting
attention is he is talking to people in
a relatable way he sounds far less like
a politician but not in a way that makes
him sound like he's delusional with
ideas that are completely disconnected
from the real world his ubi plan you can
agree with it or disagree with it you
can find areas of it that you think are
more or less feasible or more or less
advantageous but it is a very specific
policy that he has outlined now
thousands of times as he has been
running this election and it is
resonating with people even if they
don't necessarily think that's the best
way to spend government money that he is
putting out specific and actionable
plans so I think it's a combination of
personality demeanor and the fact that
he is at least attempting the stick
T'Pol
see and he has many policies out there
that many people are liking is every
single one of them completely feasible
no that's the case with any presidential
candidate is Andrew yang going to get
enough speaking time at the third debate
such that he would even have the
opportunity to really be as prominently
placed as Joe Biden Warren or Bernie
he's not and you can argue that's not
fair I mean you can make the case that
if there are ten candidates in a debate
regardless of polling each should get
ten percent of the time and I wouldn't
completely disagree with you even though
though I understand why the network's do
it the way they do it I I don't disagree
with the premise that if you really want
the debates to be an adjudication of all
of the ideas that are out there you
really should be giving the can that its
equal time although I get why they don't
so I think that's what it is I think
what Andrew yang has done I know that
he's talking about this is not to now go
away in a month this is to become
president of the United States I don't
see how the numbers point to him doing
that in the same way that I didn't see
it with Tulsi and Tulsi has not even
made the third debate and there are
still people saying she's going to be
President I think at some point we have
to be a little more realistic but I
think that Andrew Yang's presidency has
been good for the Democratic Party I
think it's been good for elections in
general and I'm interested in seeing how
far he goes